this year 2021 is on track to be the
deadliest year for gun violence in the
past two decades the cdc says on average
more than 100 people a day are killed by
firearms in this country and this
epidemic of gun violence led one organ
artist to create the so-called soul box
project it inspires people to fold small
paper boxes to show
lives impacted by all this violence
thousands of boxes went on display at
the national mall in washington and we
visited the exhibit and spoke to some of
the people involved
[Music]
my name is leslie lee i am the founder
and director of the sole soulbox project
this whole box project is something that
i started
right after the las vegas shooting a
gunman fired hundreds of shots into the
outdoor crowd at an outdoor concert 58
people were killed i was horrified by
the event the numbers were so huge
i was just thinking
our brains are not wired to absorb
numbers like that and as an artist
i felt like it was important that there
be a visual
the origami boxes were
just the first thing that came to mind
each one of them is going to represent a
victim of gunfire they needed to be
something that anybody could make
this is what you call a soul box
we're doing this for j.c
my name is giselle merk and i am the
mother of j.c webster
who was
murdered july of 2017 due to gun
violence
[Music]
j.c he
when he was born
his hair came in on the top of his head
like the sign of a cross it also looked
like he had a mohawk
and he
just beautiful
you know jc is a kidder he's a joker he
always wanted to make people smile to
make people laugh
just gives you this hug and it's a
sweets
and then he just lifts you up
and he'll put you down
you know i miss his hugs
i miss his hugs
this was back home in the islands
the detective and the
hospital doctor came in told me jc
didn't make it then i asked well
may i see my son
and
that's when um
it was told to me
that i could not
so i couldn't hug
my hugger
this is so nice of soul box to do this
the soul box
it's healing
because
while you're making
while you're making these boxes
you're thinking about
your loved one
we have two hundred thousand boxes that
we have brought to the mall to display
which in total
represents about three years worth of
gunfire deaths and injuries this is the
nation's front yard
and this is where national attention
comes
and they look so young
it's really hard to think about about
those moms and families and what they're
going through i teach and i talk with
kids every day about gun violence but
just seeing this you know it brings it
home a lot
my daughter was allison parker she was
the journalist who was murdered on live
television in 2015. she was 24 years old
she was just starting her life
and it was cut short seeing that box
that gives me comfort
[Music]
my jc
oh
art doesn't tell you what to do this
project doesn't say anything about
taking away people's guns what this is
about
is reaching people's hearts so that they
understand that if they have a gun they
need to be responsible with it thank you
ever so much
for jc to be represented here
it's healing because
we were able to create
that box
to show hey look
jc
his life matters
[Music]
boys you heard their art does not tell
you what to do and neither does
journalism but that is a lot of
fatalities